all right let's do this today we're
gonna see if someone with no haircutting
experience can give a decent haircut I
think I can give Brighton a decent
haircut I'm gonna try really hard
hopefully I don't screw it up no I don't
think I'm gonna give a great haircut my
name is Derek Henderson and I'm a barber
and I've been cutting hair for five
years I currently work at Union shave in
Saugerties New York and All American
barbershop I'm here to judge damaged
your haircuts and I'm gonna fix them
when they finish I don't think these
haircuts are gonna tell me how to well
you terrified yes what kind of haircut
do you want today can you try to give me
a tight fade on the back and sides and
then keep it long on the top just a trim
at the top I'm not going too crazy
because again I don't trust John here we
go I'm feeling really confident right
now I'm liking how this is going how do
you feel do you feel okay I'm sweating
really really I'm feeling I'm feeling
confident I'm not about Jeff oh dude
your hands pretty shaky right now how do
you think I'm doing so far good good
this is a good approach yeah I mean he's
doing all right everything look even
yeah might not be that bad I'm confident
back he will really like it so I'm gonna
start sorry I can see this I'm really
concerned about the top portion here
because this is really you can't sphere
this up that is not what I want to hear
today I'm gonna spin it out first right
how do you like it then no let's just
give it a short trim at the top all
right so I'm gonna thin it out first if
no rhyme or reason for I'm going
[Music]
good I'm just gonna take a child here
stop saying that that's my ear that's my
ear again soon I'm gonna break skin all
right brain thank you what do you think
not bad not half a half wait half decent
job J yeah
dude would you like to see it I don't
know if I didn't want to but I guess I
should what the [ __ ] dude it looks good
oh there's a little patchy this year can
you see the back do you see your bald
spot oh my god over all this my bad the
bald spot on the back whoops
but like if you don't look hit this side
I think that's not I don't think that's
not bad and the styling I think the
swish is still in I think it's a thing
I'm really proud of right now my plan to
fix this is I have to try to find what
this length is even this whole top out
bring down these sides oh yeah it's
salvageable sure first first time the
second time wasn't so so bad on the side
the top was more of the issue kind of
was able to take it down a little bit on
top looks great yeah looks good now I
think I came into it thinking short hair
more masculine cut I could just buzz it
off I don't know it was just a lot of
layers it was about what I expected is
very very difficult but I think it's
been the day you never do much I think
this is kind of what it looked like when
I finished I think I found myself in the
profession
[Music]